great dude she's gonna you know what my
wife's in the in the bathroom taking a
plopper taking a one pound bobber
one pound blobber
hello hello hello
[Music]
I don't want people to know it's a shirt
that's so cool I don't want to wear it
on the show I don't want anybody to know
you're talking about I saw it once in a
window
at a store that I was driving by and I
never was able to go back to get it
because it wasn't there when I went back
and I've been looking for it for like
over a year that shirt no no no not this
one oh no sure I would never wear the
shirt if I ever do get it I'm not
wearing it on the show I don't want
other people to love it oh you're not
even talking about this shirt no no not
this shirt this shirt is very very sick
Looney Tunes virtual well because you
don't want the other another person to
get that why didn't you get the shirt
when you drove by because I was going
somewhere and I thought like I'll just
go back because it's a store because
then what and it wasn't there what yeah
wow that's crazy it's like one of those
shitty stores on like pico that just has
like Los Angeles stuff when did you go
back
like a week too late too long I know but
it's like it was in the window too
stupid you should have went when you
were done with doing whatever you're
doing yeah I was already late to the
thing I was going to which made me late
to the next thing now oh so I'm a busy
guy dude this was a year ago I'm a busy
guy you tell me what the shirt is off
air okay I'll see what I can do okay
great it's Italian but you know what
um
okay I spilled coffee on my shirt and I
don't know if you could see it on on
camera I doubt you can but I can see it
but thank God I wore this shirt because
it's like it's a little coffee kind of I
mean it's a little greenish but it's a
little bit like coffee kind of it Blends
it's like yeah it's like Earth Tone and
then you pour another Earth Tone on it
yup yeah Earth Tone City dude I
absolutely spilled it and I got pissed I
was gonna wear a white shirt too Duke
dude
yeah I can't imagine the hell that would
ensue if I had a white shirt on and that
spilled all over the place what what
kind of hell
when you get mad at yourself are you the
kind of absolute [__] who's like
makes it miserable for everybody else
too no what I do is I get mad at myself
and the only reason why I get mad at
myself the only reason
I get extra mad at myself and the only
reason is so then when I I feel okay
getting mad at other people when they
mess up because I go well I get mad at
myself too
what uh
up brain dude a faulty brain oh yeah see
oh wait see
I don't know I get mad at myself
you know why boy I'm not I'm joking
about Australian I'm joking about
um that I'm joking about that okay there
you go okay okay
um but I did spill coffee all over the
place and all over oh oh oh I spoke all
over the place remember that no what's
that
I'm not gonna tell the story I choose
not to wow wow yeah
um but look dude it's Sunday and Sundays
are for Lifeline so there we go patreon
is we're Lifeline luxury we got Lifeline
luxury which is kicking of kicking off
dude it's just amazing we got a lot of
patreons over there it's patreon.com
Lifeline luxury patreon.com lifetime I
mean everyone never put the slash I know
and I want you to okay
uh and uh I am going to be in let's see
well for the last zombie tonight right
now I'll be the last night in Vegas and
then uh I will be in Brea and also uh uh
Irvine Orange County coming up here I
think tomorrow I'm in one of them uh and
then I have Charlotte North Carolina
uh Knoxville
uh
uh what else do I have Little Rock
Arkansas Nashville's coming up
Calgary Alberta and also Edmonton and
then a bunch of other ones like Montreal
so yeah go to chrisley.com to get them
tickets go ahead
oh uh you got a question what's up you
got a question for us you want to be on
the show clicking the link click the
link in the description below or go to
watch lifeline.com you got two ways to
do it there's no excuses or leave us a
message uh On The Hotline you don't want
to show your face at
213-973-8095 you want one-on-one advice
with me me and only me you go to my
website matalia.com and book a session
it's just me and you we figure out all
of your problems and your life is
unbelievably great after that and last
but not least perhaps the most in fact
is the merch you got to get the merch
you don't have the merch you don't have
every piece of the merch you're failing
you're failing us you know you got to
get it all at lifelinemerch.com
so stop failing us and get everything
dude oh okay what it's so rude to say
it's all good while someone else is
speaking
lifelinemerch.com it's good though man
um so yeah I am this is before I went to
Vegas we're recording this and I'm in
Vegas now it's uh 117 degrees in Las
Vegas that's what it says it's gonna
happen I want to know
what's up you know what's up you got to
finish that's too hot right so I like
the Heat and apparently a bunch of
people are flocking to uh what is it
Desert Valley what do they call it Death
Valley Death Valley
um because it's going to be the highest
temperature in history
for uh something like thousands and
thousands and thousands of years and
tourists are going it's gonna be 135 in
Death Valley imagine going to that on
purpose don't do that well that's what
they're doing I don't know I would think
like you know Saudi Arabia gets super
Death Valley is always breaking records
that Valley is the thing it is pretty
where is Death Valley like it's like
close close enough but not like super
close I think it's like I don't know
what it's north right from here but it's
in it's in California yes dude it's
crazy the hottest place on Earth is
really close to where we live we must be
really special me wow
is in between yeah Las Vegas and that is
crazy that it gets so hot there what's
that all about I'm 35 is nuts that's
what they said and tourists are going
and some people are gonna die I mean
they deserve it well no it's like going
to a war zone and being like oh we're
gonna experience it you know it's not
like going to a war zone you know it
could be
what if there's people shooting each
other there then it's a war zone then
well then it's a shoot Zone it's not
necessarily Awards of war is a lot of
shooting I believe I would hold a lot of
shooting I would invest I would venture
to Guess that it's called Death Valley
for a reason because they die but not
because they get shot because it's War
there no no I know but I'm saying it's
also a risk to go to Death Valley but
yeah anyway no I think that's kind of
bullsh honestly because it's like Death
Valley is like they're what else are
they gonna call it they got to call it
Death Valley they gotta call it death
something heat Valley
they could call it he double hockey
sticks Valley that would have been cool
hell Valley hell no he double hockey
sticks okay or spelled out all right
double hockey sticks that is so dumb
it's pretty cool I like to say welcome
to one hockey stick I find
one a hockey stick if line no one hockey
stick iPhone one hockey stick Ein one
hockey stick ice the other hockey stick
Ein yeah yeah okay that's how you
pronounce this show my back hurts yes oh
dude where's your backer uh wherever I
go what part of your back uh the middle
part that's always what happens is it
near your spine yeah
I mean all right you know why I gotta be
defensive what else no I just want to
know if we have the same place where it
hurts up mine is like
up it's hard up mine's right here mine's
here no it's it's better to be up here
yeah why this is just means I'm doing it
doing it better the higher the better
though really
why oh I'm sorry the lower the better is
what I mean why well because then you
get the rest of your body to chill
no I don't believe that how about that
guy who came up to us asked us to take a
picture of his license I was
and I was so confused that I wasn't I
know you weren't actually he asked me I
know and you get a lot of spittle in his
mouth it was disgusting ew I didn't even
notice that I'm very very I'm very
observed say what he did
he goes like this hey can you um oh
actually you messed up do you know you
messed up right yeah I did yeah yeah but
but I didn't okay go go go what did he
say first
can I ask you a question
can I ask you a question and I was and I
was like what's up
and he said
explain this long no that's not what
happened
then you do it I don't remember what he
said first oh he doesn't remember
it was over and then you said why what's
up and I go oh no it wasn't over it was
beginning he asked me can I ask you a
question
and I said what's up yes no it's the
only part I actually really remember it
didn't happen okay hello I didn't happen
tell it the way you you think it
happened I don't remember what he said
first so I kind of who cares just do the
rest he goes so he goes whatever it was
right he did do that it was a statement
and then you say oh
hey guys
oh no no that's what he said yes dude he
goes like this does this not work
no you said you guys work here that's
what he said dude no no no no no wrong
he's wrong wrong he said do you guys
work here first thing he said Matt look
at us we don't work at a parking lot
that's why I was like this guy's gonna
try to Rob us because we so obviously
don't work here so then even more so why
do you drag it out I get robbed he said
do you work her I said no and then what
am I supposed to do why what do you need
what you said why what's up that is the
mess up no I didn't do that you did do
that okay well I regret it so it didn't
happen
[Laughter]
the things that I regret they actually
didn't happen wow so it's all good
anyway he wanted to take a it was so it
made me mad because it was so confusing
it wasn't it it was he didn't explain it
right the reason why it's confusing is
because of how stupid the app is that we
didn't create it was a lime scooter
thing that he wants to get on and he was
like I don't have my license but they
want me to take a picture of my license
but I I have a picture of my license so
can you take a picture of my license on
your phone which is the wrong way to say
that he should have said the app only
accepts pictures that you take while
you're in the app not pictures from your
library that you can upload he didn't
say that all he said was music man what
he said was I need a picture of my
license
and I have a picture of my license can I
take can you use your phone to take a
picture of my picture
and I was like you have the thing you're
asking me to take double hockey sticks
no right yeah but anyway I did it and I
was like dude it's not gonna work and he
was trying to scan a picture of his
license yeah a picture of a picture of
his license from my phone which was so
reflecting yeah and it was so bright out
yeah that I was like bro it's not gonna
work it looks at me goes like this oh
it's not and I'm like nah
uh so anyway that's trying to touch your
phone though and I literally I literally
got in like my knees bent I was like
this something yes he was you kept going
like you don't remember he was trying to
touch it and you kept going like this
like a little further no no no because
he was too close I was trying to zoom
pull it out that's why I'm trying to
pull it out because I'm like dude you're
not getting it right he wasn't trying to
touch my phone he was trying to steal
something from us no he wasn't I kept
looking around where's the pickpocket
I'm smart I know I know I don't know I
understand I would wear that as well but
also it was fine it was fine nothing
happened I listened to a lot of Dateline
we both don't have our wallets you know
we didn't realize it right now wait a
minute wait a minute
wait wait hold on a second okay
um I have a different haircut he did my
hair okay
um all right Chris is back oh yeah Chris
is back here he's going for way too long
that's what I wanted to talk about
actually I wanted to talk about the fact
that
he was gone for too long the thing about
going away is that it can be great but
if it's too long it's worse what do you
think the most it's worse than not going
oh yeah you know what I'm saying yeah
which but he did it too long so he
shouldn't have gone at all oh it was too
long for you or me uh objective
objectively yeah
it was so you you can't go away for 25
days unless you're in rehab
was it 25 days yeah that's so long dude
what were you thinking what were you
thinking over there I don't know you
were thinking huh it's too long yeah I
was after a while by the end you were
what's up what's the main way to go in
how long away uh two weeks is the cap oh
man that's way too long it's the cap
it's that is when it gets to be
infuriating
after two weeks it's infuriating I would
never want to go away for more than 10
days
10 days I would say 10 days is the cap
ultimate after 10 you go I gotta get
home after two full weeks I'm infuriated
yeah it was hard it was not it was not
easy uh after a while and then I hit
this point where it actually felt kind
of good and and different to be away I
don't even remember ever being are you
on the mic yeah you uh you got bent into
submission by your by your own vacation
I would say it had Unos I have the exact
amount of time you should go away okay
six days six days is good yeah six days
is good six days swinger six days
um all right cool well we figured it out
we didn't figure it out and he went away
for four times that oh man you know what
I'm saying good at math yeah thank you
all right well let's get into Lifeline
you know if you want to listen to
Lifeline luxury there's more of this
just bantering having fun it's lovely uh
so you go to uh patreon.com uh Lifeline
luxury but if not
stay tuned and right now we're going to
get into our submissions okay
wow what's up Christian man welcome
suitcase under his face appreciate a
little bit of advice if you could give
it to me I've had this mustache get rid
of it next one out three years oh whoa
and I'm going to shave it off next week
nice and I already know what's coming
all right everybody's gonna tell me the
same questions over and over yeah what
happened to your mustache why'd you save
your mustache it's annoying and no I
kind of just hate answering those
questions over and over again in the
world you guys have any like cool
one-liners that you guys can give me
there's roller coaster behind them you
know make it more interesting than the
regular answer just like
because I wanted to I really don't have
a reason why I'm saying the richest guy
in the world dude so let me know how the
cops you guys have any cool little
one-liners there a few gorillas in
Kansas
conversation more interesting okay
appreciate it oh I got some pretty good
I'm such sprawling uh [__] property
so all what you can say which I think
would put a kibosh on it pretty quickly
would so uh they say hey what happened
to your mustache and you say and you go
like this oh yeah oh I must have left it
on your mom's [__] okay well you know
that is
so rude no because he doesn't want the
questions he wants him to stop I must
have left it on your mom's [__] dude
yes that's hilarious yeah say it loud so
everybody else hears okay what if his
wife's uh mom his mom talking about his
own grandmother-in-law that's dead
um you go like this you should first of
all you shave your mustache
keep it okay put it in a baggie okay
back pocket disgusting as hell but not
really it's his hair you go like this
how many muscles like this I got right
here
nothing I got it that's awesome mine's
better uh yours is more like fun loving
yeah mine's more confrontational loving
conversational loving yeah wow
confrontation loving
um I think that you should uh that's a
good idea yeah it is good if you want to
actually
um if you actually want to
really really stop them in their tracks
oh and they say well having your
mustaches go like this I have cancer
and then they go
look at the chemo got got rid of it and
you feel bad now don't you yeah so don't
ask me personal questions and then you
spin move out of there right
okay those are three great questions
those are great three good questions
it's probably horrible but I'll say it's
great thank you I mean
I think that would be funny especially
if like if it's the [__] I left already
around his [__] yeah that's that's
that's what you say and if it's in a
group of friends yeah everybody will
like it oh it's like even better go like
this what
I mean
ruin the bit I'm sorry because I'm
[__] Tick Tock ruining a bit wow that
was bad dude
when your best friend's friend says best
friend or whatever uh at least uh he
didn't stop on the joke you could just
be looking around now start over
he doesn't want him he doesn't want to
Chris you [__] it up I know how to do
it I don't blame you that you don't want
to yeah it's pissed me off time yeah I
was gonna say go look oh oh yeah and
then you go oh and then leave go inside
a house come out of the house and be
like
right
hello yeah no just call me back um then
okay so yeah so long
I think I lived in your mom's [__]
ten minutes you know everyone's like
what is he talking about I'm gonna
forgot come with me you get in the car
you drive over to like a local
McDonald's and you look under the
napkins
dude I think it's in your mom's [__]
take a whole day for it
that guy's just like hey don't care you
know
I was just asking because I noticed you
know that's what we got to stop doing
what you gotta stop everyone needs to
stop asking people about things just
because they noticed I totally agree
I've been saying you can't be doing it
like that I've been saying this okay
good I've been saying this
I've been saying this and I've been
thinking about how when like if you have
so
so these shoes right you look at these
shoes they're from they're divk they're
great shoes love them
um
people sometimes say oh nice shoes you
know yeah
if these were bright red every they
would get way more compliments yeah yeah
and they're only saying that because of
the color yes right right so they're
dum-dums it's not that the shoe's better
it's actually probably worse but I've
done the thing where like I've even done
it when I don't mean it yeah yeah and
I'm like what I know you're like whoops
I felt victim what am I doing I Feel
Victim you know it's like I saw I get it
but I also hate that about when I do it
too yeah I know I try to limit it but
sometimes you fall victim you know yeah
but then there are the people that do a
weird thing just and they just want you
to ask then I walk down the street like
this I hold them back I hold back my
legs looking not something I refuse to
give them what they want when I sense
that that's that's good that's good
people should do that more yeah all
right next one
hey what's up guys all right start over
come on here we go Omaha Nebraska I mean
solo you look [__] great Chris you
look funky
um I have a dilemma for you guys
um my dad has been attacked by a shark
twice in the same area he keeps swimming
um in the same area the first time that
he was attacked because they have uh
rehabbing he would say that it wasn't
the shark's fault he was just doing what
he was supposed to do okay yeah and he
would go back to the same spot even
after rehability rehabilitating his his
uh muscles and doing all this stuff he'd
go back
um and then he was attacked within two
weeks of being in that spot again
and um the second time he went back
after two months and he's attacked again
same spot he won't switch up his
swimming spot I'm trying to get him to
do that he won't
um me and my sisters and my mom have
told him that even though the nature of
a shark is to attack and eat and do what
it's supposed to do you still shouldn't
put yourself in that position in the
same spot we're trying to move down the
beach through different spot he won't do
it
I'm hoping you guys will uh like
reiterate our point and just tell him
like
no matter how many times you go back to
the same spot no matter how many times
you rehab
the shark's still going to do what the
shark does and you need to move your
swimming spot so please just help me get
this through to him
I would really appreciate it yeah
um I got you I love you both thanks
Chris you
you in in the timing apart and and uh
everything
so much just thank you guys okay wait
let me know what you think so him
him your dad the response of Dad you
need to stop going in there like you get
attacked by a shark and your dad's
responsive well the shark's just doing
what the shark is supposed to do is the
same as this you say pretend I'm the dad
and you say okay yeah there
sharks are usually uh blue or gray
it's the it's a non response that's not
a professional response right yeah what
about
do with anything yeah shark's gonna do
what the shark's gonna do
oh Marco
what's going on oops
what's going on
why do you keep playing [__] music
what are you doing I'm not trying to no
[__] but you're doing it
that's just as much as a non-responsible
it doesn't even matter if I try to
explain it but
what's happening stop is what matters
okay
what's happening is
it was on there and I locked the phone
so then I opened the phone to look
something up and it's still on it's got
nine computers there wow look at look at
how about a goddamn nine computer turn
the sounds down
yeah I get it I get it it's like when I
was when I was watching porn and then I
took my uh laptop over to Starbucks and
I opened it up and it goes oh yeah
that used to happen sometimes when I
would start my car
what are you laughing at because I would
start the car like uh like Lauren was in
the car you know Bluetooth needs to get
better with that [__] yeah don't do it
don't pull up XVideos
I was watching on a safari dude you know
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah it's always that
one too the flat note
oh yeah the swallow first
so this guy's dad
uh answers questions with non-answers
and that should be highlighted next time
he says that stupid ass wrong
yeah so don't let him say that because
that is a non-answer
uh it's good I guess to have some kind
of sense of exposure therapy but it's
not that he's scared he's not like I'm
scared I need to face my fears and go
back yeah this guy's like an idiot
version of Captain Ahab you know I mean
I gotta goes that he's the guy who tries
to kill Moby Dick and he always gets
attacked by it but keeps going I know
he's the main character or not really
the main character I know he's the
captain of the show's a character
constantly trying to kill Moby Dick dude
I don't
you know like mangled him and ravaged
his body but he keeps going back because
it's his you know it's my white whale
that's like what that means no I don't
know you lived in the world you ever
lived in the world you ever lived in the
world with people my white whale dude I
like that yeah it's cool that's really
nice it's like The elusive thing that
you always want yep yep yep
um yeah well I uh there's that Ian
Edwards joke that's [__] hilarious
you should look it up whatever but where
he's like you're going into the shark's
house that'd be like if somebody comes
in your house and
I don't know I'm ruining the joke it's
hilarious look it up but but he's funny
he's very funny but uh yeah but um yeah
it's just you you're you're this is the
shark's Place yep and and you know this
now because of twice this happened once
maybe it could have been a mistake maybe
or should be like hey what's going on is
that a seal ah [__] it freak accident
but now this you know the shark's like
get out of my [__] place yeah it's
basically like hey like if you're with a
group of people and you're like let's go
to the park and throw the ball around
yeah uh and someone's like I don't I'd
rather not go to the park let's go into
a guy's house and throw the ball like
well you don't do that because
somebody's gonna get really mad at you
because you're in their property and
they're gonna probably shoot you here's
another thing too if you're let's go to
the park and throw the frisbee around
yeah but there's a lion there
a park belongs to us more than the ocean
and you're being like this about the
ocean yeah yeah so I was almost like I
have a question does he want to die bro
what's what he might want to die what's
wrong with me I keep I spelled I mean
you might as well keep going you know
yeah well he might want to die yeah
people have a weird thing like that like
they're like
people have weird thing with that kind
of stuff death you know they secretly
want it you know yeah the Death Drive
dude the Death Drive the Death Drive is
that something yeah is that something
like the white whale well similar but
it's it's if it's if you're saying is it
like the white well in the sense that
someone long ago wrote about it yes I
never heard about the Death Drive Death
Drive it's like this the sex drive but
it's like uh oh you are born and then
you are immediately sort of the Allure
of death is very strong that you are
seeking it in indirect ways uh sometimes
not so indirect usually latent ways
okay you good yeah I don't think I have
that I don't want to die no but I mean
people I think people don't realize that
they the point is they it's latent they
don't realize that they have it but
they're just starting the word Layton
trying to so it's like a latency period
just learn the word late it's like a
latency wow all right situation yeah
yeah dude I mean you know you have an
intervention with your dad you know how
the shark show up maybe slap your dad in
the face no that's because sometimes it
takes like a real shaking up to really
get a point across also how about this
have you actually
have you actually had a one-on-one where
you sat with your dad or called your dad
and said hey it really worries me I know
this may be my thing maybe well I'm
asking you don't swim there yeah please
yeah have you done that that could work
that should be the last line of defense
and if you haven't done that you should
do that yes but I mean at a certain
point like
he's just being such a Titanic [__]
this guy's people who love him he likes
to go swimming he won't change his
swimming place or swimming route
whatever the hell it's killing people
tell me what to do just
like dude a shark is eating you yeah
it's weird dude
also that's so annoying when somebody's
like dude I don't bro if if a shark
bites me yeah I'm not adopting the
[__] thing where people go like
that's just what sharks do and I can't
be mad at it nature does what it does
dude I'm so pissed off at that shark
well that's you know what you're right
you do that [__] because just as much as
the shark's gonna do what it's gonna do
is right what should also be right is
that the person that the shark bites
wants to [__] kill this and I'm gonna
kill I'm gonna go I'm gonna kill it I
want to kill it that's what nature kind
of give me dude these hero type
[__] that are like you know
what that's nature I can't fault the
shark for being a shark [__] that dude
I'm so pissed off at that shark if it
bites me but that's what I'm saying if a
gazelle gets half eaten by a lion it's
not just like wow this is what Lions do
continue
you know what I'm saying yeah humans are
the only ones that are like hey that's
just nature I want to you know yeah all
animals do you know oh well that's a
different thing I think dogs cats
rabbits wow if the rabbits were big we'd
be [__]
you ever think about that never one in
fact I'm not even thinking about it now
that's how much I don't think about it
if uh if Yorkies were big then that
would be the greatest thing in the world
though like 10 feet tall they would kill
us oh they were the same way
well then they would smother us and we
wouldn't breathe and they'd crack our
bones when they sit on our laps yeah
exactly and that's where I was gonna go
with that okay go ahead next all right
hey guys lifelong fan
um me and my girlfriend just moved into
our new place
um
I can decorate the whole apartment
except for the office because that's her
space and she hasn't
touched it um it's driving me nuts and I
don't know how to deal with this what do
you guys recommend appreciate it good
option bit opposite on the crazy cool
cross
I mean are you doing Mad Libs what what
was that last part he literally was
bleeding out and dying crazy cold heart
and that was his final question dude I
uh that's opposite I don't give a [__]
about decorating and usually guys don't
but this guy does and and the woman's
it's the backwards completely
traditionally it's definitely
traditional woman has the office and it
she's only allowed to Decor only wants
to or whatever it is decorates that room
even the office part is usually I know
everything about it yeah yeah yeah and
uh
and she won't decorate the office and
he's decorating the rest of the house
that's hilarious he's like and you know
she won't shave her balls anytime I ask
her to you're just like wait wait wait
wait what you know
um but yeah she doesn't like my aprons
that I wear and my bra she never
compliments me with my tits
um so she watches porn all day um so
tell her
yeah that is driving you crazy and that
if she doesn't want to do it I'm happy
to help that's the thing like you want
to you want it to be done up decorated
somehow not necessarily in your style
because it's not your space but it
bought it bothering you that there's
nothing done to that one room in your
new home it's totally understandable but
what you should say is hey how do you
want this room to be I'll help you in
fact I'll do it for you but just like
all I need from you is you to tell me
what you want yeah that's it
yeah just just she obviously doesn't
care if you haven't done which is kind
of how I am which I can totally relate
to I don't really care but if someone
was like hey someone I trusted and loved
was like Hey however you want this room
to be like I'll do it for you just tell
me what you want yeah I would always be
like oh okay well maybe I won't tell me
how you want it to be yeah yeah you'd be
like I want dinosaurs up and [__]
because yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay yeah dude cool uh that's
a weird uh that's that's just
interesting that he cares and she
doesn't I mean that's not that I mean
that's crash I'll write a book on that
Trilogy all right um all right next one
okay so hi guys hope you're doing well
um just a bit of context before I reveal
um I've been married to my beautiful
wife for four years but we've been
together for 14 years uh we are high
school sweethearts so we grew a lot
together thankfully that's not the
problem why I'm sending this in uh my
problem is that anytime I go to
um foreign country for a trip like
hiking or a festival with a friend
um and anytime she doesn't come with me
um I already feel homesick leading up to
the departure date yeah and I miss her
even more throughout the trips so
I feel like these are tough emotions to
deal with and that's mainly the reason
why I'm sending this in to ask for help
on how to deal with these situations
um what I want to add is that she's
totally fine with this and uh I don't
want to sound like I do this every two
weeks every year during summer time I go
to one Festival like or one trip uh one
hiking trip with one of my buddies so
it's not like this happens every week so
yeah
um
I don't know how to deal with these
emotions I hope it's not these are not
the signs of heavy codependence or
separation anxiety but you decide I
don't know I feel like I just suffer so
much it's sometimes very tough to be
away from her for extended periods of
time you know yeah I don't want to drag
this on too much thank you for all you
do guys thanks I appreciate it truly
exactly loves metal like death metal and
that's how guys who like death metal oh
that's what they're like they're like
dude what is it about Metal shirts that
they try to make it so you can't read it
I don't know it's just it's just like
the culture of but what what is that
Anthony what is gate creeper yes creeper
yeah creeper yeah it's a band what death
metal it yeah it's like that of course
okay yeah you know what it is yeah uh
okay well it's romantic comedy that
[__] Ed Burns is in it did uh so I
think that
I mean there's a few things going on
creeper starring Ed burn you could be
codependent you could be just
like it could be like an anxiety thing
you know like your normal routine is
messed up and the person that you do
those routines with is not there and you
sort of get you associate all that with
this one individual it could be a lot of
things but what I would suggest is you
say it's like once a year you go on this
trip you know and you're away from her
for however many days and it makes you
feel not so great I would say scatter
throughout the year like have like days
not overnight but like long stretches
where you are apart so I think that like
you can do like a baby step because I
would imagine that if this is how you
feel you guys are together all the time
because if it wasn't you would be used
to it I could identify with this though
man especially the I get homesick before
I leave before I leave I get sad that
I'm leaving because I don't want to
leave my wife and yeah I get that yeah
[__] and then as soon as I say okay see
ya
right it all goes away do you know what
I mean I and then I start to miss them
again it's like it resets
and then
I'll be okay because I'm worried about
what it's going to be then when it
happens I'm like oh I don't have to
worry about this I actually know how to
be by myself right yeah and then as it's
like it resets to regular and then as
the time grows I miss more and more yeah
but but that's not what happens to you
you're saying you get you me you miss
them immediately and you miss them the
whole time before and during yeah it's I
mean definitely sounds like codependency
to me but I'm not a doctor but yeah uh
but also what does your phones have been
together for so long it's like I think
that might be part of it though you're
you're so used this is why I'm
recommending what I was recommending
this guy's so you it's familiarity yeah
even if it sucked you might miss the
person because like there's this huge
the usual thing it's it's like you're
always with someone and then when you're
apart you kind of feel like you're not
whole and it doesn't necessarily have
anything to do with codependency it can
just have to do with the fact that
you're so used to it that it feels like
you're not
doing it right when someone is separate
from you and that's why I'm recommending
like try like if you have friends that
are not her try like doing like little
day trips with them maybe more often so
you can get used to this thing that it
doesn't have to be so overbearing I
wonder if it has anything to do with the
overnight stuff too like I wonder if
he's gone all day if he feels that way
because if he's gone all day and he
feels that way then it's definitely a
real actual problem
I feel like gone all day meaning like if
he leaves at 6am before she wakes up and
then comes home
while she's either going to sleep or
after she sleeps if she's like man today
sucked because I didn't get to see her
right then you got to work on yourself
yeah you know maybe she's just so
amazing though all right she could be
maybe she's so amazing that like
that's why he can't bear to not be with
her
is giving them sloppy toppy all day
giving them money all the time yeah give
him back massages and foot massage your
machines okay well nobody wants those
they're kind of cool man they would
here's a bald head would be cool to
watch him go over his bald head the
Micro Machines yeah I remember if it
doesn't say Micro Machines it's not the
real thing remember that guy of course
that guy everyone's like oh he talks
fast and it's like Busta Rhymes was like
hold my tongue but no dude you know I
saw an interview with him once because I
was kind of obsessed you know how like I
get obsessed with like I saw that weird
ass what you did and he's like I can
actually I can actually oh looky looky
looky looky looky looky we're here
okay go ahead
um
he
you saw the interview it was like I can
recite some like book or something yeah
yeah yeah yeah or some song and it was
like a Michael Jackson song it was like
18 seconds he did it all man right right
right right right right I remember I saw
that it was like bad or something yeah
the song Bad yep
yeah
thank you
screw you know that's not fast it's also
not bad
I know it's that's uh Billie Jean yeah
did you remember the [__] David
Letterman thing where he was like
somebody called in and they were like
David Letterman does I always think I I
want to know what Michael Jackson says
in the song Billie Jean it sounds like
he says but the chair is not my but the
chair is not my son right and he was
like I don't know let's listen to it and
they played it and it was like but you
know it goes how it goes but the can is
it goes like this but that chair like
they just put somebody saying chair in
it
ah all right next one
I have been on a few dates with this
girl recently and things are going very
very well I see the potential for a
long-term relationship and uh it's great
great uh all to say though we're both in
careers we might not be in the same city
uh within you know the next six to 12
months I have members of residency I
have to go on next year that might take
me out of Houston where we're at now I
hope to stay here but we'll see she's
similarly she's in a travel position
where she you know kind of moves every
uh four to six months wow
um she's open to sticking around I get
the impression we talked about a little
bit but all to say I want to talk about
it because I don't want to you know this
just to break off in a few months I want
to I'm intentionally trying to date and
so is this something I bring up to or is
it something I wait and talk to her
about once things get a little more
serious any advice would be greatly
appreciated well don't you're you're
what he's wanting to find a lover Yeah
well yeah so you gotta yeah don't
yo see if she's just doing this for fun
she might just like the way your
mustache tickles are on her Puna he he
said he better not lose it on her uh he
said that
oh I'm a little confused he's saying why
is he asked what I took it is he's he's
he's asking what he should do about
wanting to be a longer term thing yeah
because she moves every six months and
he does too he might move into six
months as well which makes the
relationship unstable so it's like he's
like if this is a real relationship he
really likes her things are going well
but what do I do do I bring it up to her
because obviously we're both not in a
career-wise situation to be locking down
some long-term [__] I I get the Dilemma
but he was it sounds like he's willing
to be long distance for this girl yeah
but she might be but what but then it's
like but is she just like oh yeah but
I'm I'm here for four months and like
yeah just get this I think have the
conversation likes super
and in a chill way yeah and then
depending upon what she says
approach it like if she's like
meeting you where you are seemingly yeah
you can just say right then and there
and have the conversation then even
though it's pretty early in the in the
relationship but if he's solely
interested in if she's so interested in
then
yeah or if she's just like for any
reason oops for any reason she's not
like
absolutely it's a possibility that I
would stay for the right relationship
yeah
then I think a little later on you want
to be like look uh I know you said you
weren't that interested but like I am
and if and if you think that's the
problem like we maybe should end things
now yeah exactly right but have it as
casual as possible at first don't even
make it seem like yeah lean against the
wall yeah don't even make it seem like
you are asking necessarily yeah be make
it seem like you're having a
conversation about it and you can
volunteer your feelings first uh yep
because she will respond in kind because
she's a human being and if she doesn't
respond in kind she has no social skills
that you want to be with her anyway so
say listen sweet it all sweet it all
hey check this out hey come here come
here dog right uh right come here dog
okay uh yeah no I mean you know yeah
that's right thank you that's right that
was a really strong full Sam Elliott
style mustache well the other guy this
is the mustache episode uh that yawn was
too long anyway next one it was as long
as it's gonna be what do you mean how is
that [__] too long to be on it's like
four or five seconds too well how long
is it gone two or two to three seconds
you don't like this
all right go ahead tear my jaw
thanks for all you do first of all
around good stuff always crack me up
I mean just wear a different shirt you
know for the thing she's gonna be
mother-in-law is sick we did the same
thing for my father-in-law
best thing we ever did sorry can you
start I started over I was distracting
his other mustache and his Tim Dillon
persona
what's up boys
um thanks for all you do first of all
all around good stuff always crack me up
I just wanted to share my experience uh
for the guy who's soon to be
mother-in-law is sick we did the same
thing for my father-in-law
best thing we ever did still
just so happy that he was able to be
there
about a year and a half after he passed
we had a giant party all right and
everyone said it was the most fun
they've ever had because there was no
stress just food drinks dancing laughing
highly suggested uh some people were a
little butt hurt that we didn't invite
them
but uh I mean that's none of their
business get over it so uh
do what you guys think is right I highly
suggest it because uh so you'll always
have those memories so thanks we were
right that's what we said right what did
we say yeah we said uh that because his
mother-in-law was sick she was gonna die
and we said have uh get married at like
either a courthouse or just in front of
her so she can witness it and then after
she passes you have a party that's what
you said that's what we said and that's
what he did and he said he couldn't he
he highly recommends it yeah so we were
right without even knowing that it was
right we got this last episode right
yeah we were right yeah and uh and the
takeaway is that is that we're really
good at saying things but um yeah sorry
about that you know sounds like you did
it right and you got no regrets and
that's beautiful that is he clearly
can't stop death he clearly feels good
about it man taking it from that guy
he's gone through it guy who's asked us
last week who's on the fence maybe a
little bit still from what we suggested
yeah well he actually was just like what
do I do right and I came up with that I
came up with that idea solely just not
even having ill parents just figuring it
out
on my own putting myself in the
situation of other people because that's
what I you know I can do that I mean
that's the almost the definition of
being empathy I'm an empath and yeah
human being I'm an empath though okay no
you're not I'm an empath and when and
when and then what happened was in the
beginning of Life I was an empath and I
got such I got you know I got a little
bit traumatized and I kind of turned
Inward and I wasn't an empath anymore
because I put up walls right I put up a
bunch of walls and then what happened
was I've been chipping away at those
walls for the past like three four years
and I realized you know what dude I
actually am an empath it's just way way
in there it's way way down there like
the mummy remember the [__] movie
with Tom Cruise how bad it was and how
far he had to go
oh down in the ground yeah he went down
in the garage did you see it yeah I saw
it yeah he went down on the ground and
uh that's where my empathy is and I'm
finding it slowly but surely I didn't
make the I didn't mean make this whole
thing about me you made the entire thing
about you but that's why I switched it
to make it more about the mummy about
Tom Cruise
cool
all right yeah who's up baby that's good
it's not Matt and Chris that's a
question for you guys has a tattoo of
wood on it what are you supposed to do
in this situation
I was hanging out with people who were
new to the area
and then they ask me
hey is there anything fun to do around
here oh
but I don't do anything yeah that's fine
all I do is Riff and lift wow what is
Riff so do I make stuff up just lie
do I do what they should have done and
Google fun things yeah right
it's a stupid question it is a stupid
question every decently sized city is
the same yes
are there any good bars around you God
bless this guy probably yeah
is that it that was it that's hilarious
well he is right dude and I often think
about this I hate those questions man
because I mean what they're hoping for
is these people are annoying because
they think like all right every City's
got their thing what's their secret
thing what's the give me the I know what
to do I know what Google said how about
this guy yeah that says I love to travel
but I don't like to go to do what
everybody else says I like to find a
thing the real everybody who lives there
like yeah yeah yeah and you know what
it's just like yeah yeah
okay well it's just like come over and
sit down at my house for five hours then
that's what we do that's what we
Italians do we're not [__] we're not
looking at the Michelangelo paintings
all day right they're not doing that
they're [__] sitting smoking you know
what I mean hanging out with their
friends seeing a girl go by and going
that's it yelling at their children if
you're Italian I'll clean it up yeah you
know exactly yeah
yeah or crying because the show ended
you know what I mean like after every
show they cried or in Italy just crying
because yeah because yeah because
there's so much emotion going on yeah
um oh no I guess I guess my car is
beautiful look at this car
like that say
I um I don't know oh well that's great
Matt you know they deserve to be told I
don't know yeah to then be like I don't
know every place is the same there's
that cool website let me Google that for
you where you could send him a link oh
dude let me send you a link and then it
sends you the link you go to let me
Google that for you.com and then they
send you a link and they click on the
link and it shows them how to Google
what they ask which is funny just saying
just send them google.com yeah you do
that too you know yeah here you go
do you know about the site if you type
in things that you're interested in
it'll actually come up with a whole
bunch of things that you might yeah do
you know what my you know what actually
this city has that's awesome it's this
crazy [__] website if you go on it
it'll tell you where to go in the thing
you want to know what it's called Google
yeah
yeah right yeah 100 but they want they
don't I don't want the things that
Google I don't want the normally what's
the hidden spots that kind of [__] you
know yeah yeah it's annoying as [__]
make up a spot oh that's good yeah
that's really good you know or or in
like a really bad part of the city okay
well then you're in a dark alley
somewhere but only go at night you know
they're just like oh oh okay yeah tell
me there's a speakeasy and then just you
know you're gonna find the news they get
shot in the head you say you say you
wanna You're Gonna Wanna Go to Chinatown
and there's no Chinatown in the city
that you're in be like you're going to
want to find Chinatown go to Chinatown I
gotta go dude I gotta go but go to
Chinatown and they go they're just
looking around for Chinatown yeah and
they have a bad time and that's what
they deserve yeah it is
and and uh honestly that's what you do
probably even if you that's what the
locals do is look for places and they
get frustrated and then you know when
they're driving that's what the locals
do it's always frustrating their drive
so they're looking for something that's
not there they're driving so you're
welcome
all right cool yeah
um
buy another one or what
based off of your congratulations
podcast I was just listening had to
pause uh it has to do with the woman uh
in the chicken place and uh just asking
way too many questions taking way too
long not knowing what she wanted
um I am like you I am prepped ready to
go I pride myself on how the time it
takes me to order what I want it's not
that complicated it's food it's drinks
it is what it is and you already know
what you like so that being said I am
with a uh my fiance who
she is that woman no matter where we go
and uh I mean to the point where I'm I'm
like legit prepping her uh I'm like you
know taking all of her questions before
I'm gonna say ask me because I I know
the answer it's not that complicated you
know what I mean it's uh it's food it's
drinks doing your part and I think it's
almost like a tick like she she needs to
ask a question every single time uh it's
weird no matter where we are no matter
where we go it could be the simplest of
things and yet every single time it
doesn't matter how big the line is she
never looks behind her it's it's just
focused on asking
uh unnecessary questions yeah and she I
think loves doing it and it infuriates
me and
um you know like I said I prep her
beforehand and doesn't matter I wonder
what everything involved so I don't know
I don't know what it is uh my question
going over is what can I do other than
what I'm already doing which is yeah I'm
playing defense for the people who are
working there and then the whole time
kind of giving them like that I'll you
know apologetic look and then I'm
looking behind you like that's a good
guy I don't necessarily I tried not to
look behind me because I know I don't
have that watch because if I was just
like you if I was back there and I'm
looking forward I'm like you don't need
to be asking these questions you know
what I mean so
um anyways advice please anything
because it is ongoing
um internal struggles I guess and
perhaps I'm projecting I don't know but
um anyways uh Chris I am living in
Sweden been here the last five years
since uh when are you gonna do an
international tour that would be
delightful
living the life not too long ago so too
bad
so uh and you're up there so it would be
great thank you all right bye boys I
would love to go to Sweden I'm gonna go
to Sweden he'll host you dude go ahead
can I come over can I stay uh so hurry
up sweetheart to his wife so order a
chicken so I mean I've said I talk about
this all the time on podcast so go ahead
take it away then no no I'm saying so
you go why I think that
huh there's four things here's the thing
there's beef fish chicken or Salad One
Pound Fish no ladies ladies come on come
on no one pound fish the [__] is that
you know what that is you don't know
what that is oh my god dude look up
Google One Pound Fish Guy well don't
come on come on one all right anyway
what did you look it up but very very
good one pound three so is it an Indian
guy yes dude okay so what do accents so
go ahead so so go ahead so go ahead
before we look at that fish man oh man
you know that's so One Pound Fish Man is
such a [__] anime
ha ha
here it comes dude
wow he's being so insecure it's
unbelievable just wait you get so
confident that watch
he will come up to him and ask him to do
it
yeah do you
do your fish song for me
guys like from Europe
I do your fish song for me oh I mean
it's so shitty do your fish song for me
do it do you [__] song huh take a
picture with me what you're good for
don't wait don't worry a [__] good
for do your [__] little ditty song
[Music]
one more
money
[Music]
it is
very very good oh very very good
[Music]
I mean it doesn't start no he does this
all day works he works at these places
obviously he works there
family
medicine
so he made a song like a really glossy
music video no yeah yeah there's a whole
music video for it can you find that
Viral I had no idea
um
when a few years ago
all right so
um well he's so Indian that second one
down second one down he's so Indian that
when you do it I can tell he's Indian
and you're a terrible well that's not
wait what
it probably goes into it
oh yeah it does yeah
when did this go viral
map the the oh I don't know well how
many years ago years ago which is which
is what I said
money
oh so bad so bad dude a priest
a priest
so bad
you'd go off to this in Vegas though
dude yeah
yeah
dude uh I'll be in Vegas speaking of
which I'll be rocking this out oh I know
I know I'll be that guy should open for
you yeah oh my God I can follow it yeah
everyone said oh
God I'd be like okay guys guys guys guys
guys come on give it to me what about
this guy so uh all right so uh anyway
um so yeah that how do we get to that
what were we talking about the caller
the guy that asked about his girl why
did you start saying one pound for years
why did you start doing that
that's so dumb you know I don't know why
we went off on such a tangent I was just
so in the zones feeling it I was okay so
anyway what should the guy do uh right I
always talk about this on my podcast I
would like to get your taken on this I
just there's four oh I said there's four
things [__] beef salad fish and he's
got a very very good it's like a [__]
[__] all right okay so I
think that I hate people who do this
yeah yeah it's just it's irresponsible
and it's okay you you she's to be a
lovely wife and everything it's just
like that's her thing it's like it's
it's like yo yo sweetie though if you're
in line here's the biggest defense yeah
when you're in line waiting to go up in
order and you get there and then you
have a bunch of questions it's like
figure it out before yeah figure it out
before that's why it's good that she has
him he's doing the work but he says it
doesn't matter I know but but I'm saying
all he can do is control what he does so
good on you bro but we need to get
deeper so I think you need to like sit
her down and be like look
why are you doing this oh it's going to
be so awful for him but like not in like
an excusitory way no I know you got to
emphasize I'm not accusing you of
anything I'm I'm asking this from the
bottom of my heart I'm curious why do
you do this because maybe the reason I'm
asking that is because maybe we can
figure out a reason or a system
that means you don't that fixes it makes
you not do it right you know right
because and then she'll be like well
what's the big deal it just annoys you
oh well boohoo that's how I am yeah but
it's inconsiderate for other people
that's what I was gonna say before you
cut me off also
when we're online though and we're
holding up a line like it has nothing to
do with me yeah uh so yeah well so
Kristen doesn't ask questions
but dude when you sit down and the
menu's there you figure it out right
because because when the when the waiter
Kristen will be like actually I haven't
even looked at the menu yet and I go
very very bad one pound fish that's not
right dude get it right know what you
want it's like the people who order it
dude there's rules there's rules you go
and you [__]
you don't sit down go to the bathroom
before the waiter comes you order first
and then go to the bathroom agree agree
yeah do we know this I agree agree it's
crazy people sit down and they're
hanging out talk a little bit they go to
the bathroom and then the waiter comes
oh hi can I get drink orders oh I'm in
the bathroom can we order food I don't
know she's taking a [__] right you know
right okay graphic but yeah she's taking
a [__] plopper dude
great dude she's gonna you know what my
wife's in the in the bathroom taking a
plopper taking a one bomb blobber
one time one pound blob one pound
plopper dude come on ladies one pun
bobber that's my nickname one that could
be a good name for the episode one pound
I thought that but I don't want to say
it live but I thought it before you no
we good
no we're not good because I thought
about that we good the biggest
[__] of all time is to do that and
we're good to do that after having sex
with someone for the first time will be
amazing and we good
oh [__] dude especially if you were two
gay guys wow very very good one pound
proper yeah uh all right so yeah you
gotta
I you know what though I gotta say I
think this might be the first submission
that I don't know what this I guess I
did give advice but I don't know if
that's gonna work talk like dude this is
a problem you might not be able to get
to the bottom culture part of the
culture talk about the thing where uh
you say people use this as like oh this
is my time I get to order now nobody's
gonna [__] with my time talk about how
you talk about that me to talk about
that yeah because it's something you
thought you told you told me about yeah
people like
when they get there's like a whole
mentality of a certain kind of customer
yeah and it's not just about food yep
it's about anything that it it's a very
American thing but I'm sure it's also
true in other places but yeah it's like
people think that they're the customer
so that when it's their moment to be
asking questions to be considerating
considering buying something
considerating uh or considerating yeah
uh it's like they not only are allowed
to take all the time that they want
right but it's their absolute right
birth given right and everyone else
doesn't get to say anything about it
because when it's their turn they will
never say anything to them it's like
they have a wrong way of thinking about
it but but it is somewhat common that
people think this way it's like a very
much customer is always right mentality
it's very corporate mentality in general
but here's the thing and let me tell you
I've never felt something more strongly
in emphatic than this the customer
is not always right no in fact the
customer is more often than not mostly
wrong really wrong right and if you
lived by that if you actually lived your
life by that rule the customer is always
right nothing would ever get done every
company would go bankrupt and nobody
would be happy in the whole [__]
world I want to have a store that says
the customer is only right sometimes on
the window great come in at your own
risk right yeah yep at your own Peril
quicker not the thing I'm at the the
what do they call the people who take
the orders not the waiters but the
people behind the counter or cashier
quicker yeah quicker it's right all
that's right there six things quicker
they're all the same thing really right
one's fried quicker right quicker yeah
quicker why you're saying quicker
because they're taking too long oh oh I
see it do I want the burger or the or
the burger with two pads well you could
do that I mean yeah if your place was
popular enough you could do anything
like that you know because you keep
people out and they'd be like oh my God
I got kicked out of social I just wanted
to have it it's like the no soup no soup
no soup for you that's just like funny
classic episode would you say that's the
number one classic episode of Seinfeld
okay I've gotten into this conversation
before I you have yeah I I thought so
okay but I think real Seinfeld heads
would tell me otherwise yeah there's a
lot not one but I love the show yeah I
haven't seen everyone either but I love
the show yeah but I think that we talked
about that a lot probably maybe yeah
maybe like Dad or Mom thought it was
funnier but I have some friends who
fully have seen every episode more than
once yeah and they're like
I mean God there's so many funny
episodes the Keith Hernandez episode is
hilarious no dude the [__] episode
where he
ah [__] where George has to go pitch
the thing and he has to go good night
everybody like leave your confidence do
you know that one yeah yeah yeah dude
the funny is it Twix what's the company
so the funniest character on Seinfeld is
not open for debate it's not it's not
even close it's not even close the other
people on the show are fun very funny
but everybody's the show oh it's no it's
George Costanza no question not close
here is no question let me tell you
something else people have different
opinions they'll say Jerry's is the
funniest Elaine's the funniest but if
someone says Kramer is the funniest yeah
that person is not funny the person who
said that is not funny I I I'd say on a
rare occasion they could be funny but
man they don't really actually get they
don't get once they do that yeah yeah
because it's like some guy walking in
the door looking like he got
electrocuted and Kramer is very first
everyone on that show is hilarious I'm
not but even George Costanza if I had to
pick five characters in TV that were the
greatest characters of all time yeah
dramatically or comedically yeah I have
to probably put him in the top five the
yeah the two comedy ones would be him
and him as yeah comedy ones would be him
yeah and him him and him
as the two top comedy ones I rank him
and him and then the other one would be
uh me inundateable and then me and
Whitney and then me and rush hour that
was a TV series and I played a little
guest part I don't think that that would
be you no I don't think I would pick you
I don't think anybody would pick you up
for those slots I forgot I was in that
show rush hour to be honest
okay so you you're the one that told me
that Anthony reminded me the other day
well he didn't actually remind anybody I
was talking about rush hour and he's
like that [__] show sucks and I was
like I was in that okay that's what I
realized oh okay okay okay yeah so what
do you think about that
uh well you know what I think about that
very very good one pound fish
dude Rush Hour very very cheap a One
Pound Fish the two first rush hours the
other night the movies and I watched the
third one soon how about they're making
a phone how about this movie what
remember this movie Money Talks
yeah it was remember the joke in the
trailer you fat no but Heather Locklear
is like
and Charlie Sheen's like p-h-a-t yeah
yeah
oh man movies were so good back then
yeah dude
it's a shame huh yeah it's a shame all
right it's A Low Down Dirty Shame guys
another one yeah all right cool uh I'll
be in Charlotte I'll be in Nashville
I'll be in Knoxville I'll be in Little
Rock Arkansas
um when he's in the Orange Orange County
dates in southern SoCal dates
chrisley.com thank you very much also
you can go to uh uh watch lifefeline.com
to ask us a question thank you very much
and you go to lifelinemirch.com to get
merch thank you very much and then you
want to go to the patreon is what you
really want to do and sign up for
Lifeline luxury if you haven't yet it's
patreon.com
Lifeline luxury get in there uh uh is a
great show thank you very much please
leave a a thing on the a comment on the
thing yeah and if you have a question
algorithm just tickle it up
um and then click the link in the in the
description below or just go to watch
lifetime.com you said that already yep
and then the Bell notification you get
hit and it'll [__] let you know when
we got some just [__] oh thank you
very much yeah and yeah
um oh if you want if you want a
one-on-one with me yeah make your life
way better than it already is uh let me
check your brain uh make an appointment
on mattelia.com and Chris says that
thank you very much
thank you very much all right guys
[Music]